you all of a sudden you've got I don't
know 15 cameras following around a
camera crew sound crew and in the back
of your mind you know that's going to be
televised welcome back to another
episode of the recruitment mentors
podcast I'm your host his and on this
week's episode I was joined by Ricky
Martin if they are not taking it
seriously and giving it all they are
taking someone else's opportunity 10
years ago Ricky started his very own
recruitment business called hyper
recruitment Solutions and I'd always say
you're hiring higher fail fast let
people make mistakes that's fine as long
as they learn from the mistakes but if
it's failing fail fast and it took me
too long to realize that he actually won
The Apprentice in 2012. on the
reflection of the fact Perfection so to
start this business you've got a 250
grams worth of investment it became 50
50 partners with Alan sugar and his
business Journey began there now they
have just over 45 people in the business
they did 15 million pounds worth of
Revenue last year six percent perm 40
contract that have offices in Essex
Manchester and in the process of going
over to the us as we speak I asked him
all the questions that I think people
actually want to ask him is The
Apprentice scripted is it fake is it
real and also how helpful has it
actually been having a business partner
who hasn't invested in the recruitment
business before does Ricky regret giving
50 of his business away we discuss it
all along with scaling what he learned
his biggest mistakes Ricky's nothing but
honest in this episode so enjoy it into
the episode Ricky welcome to the podcast
thanks for having me mate thanks for uh
making the trip
from uh Essex Hometown Sunny Essex right
yeah Sunny Essex now I appreciate you
coming over uh really looking forward to
dig into this journey that you've been
on
um super interesting and I think four
people listening I just always like to
start by just giving people some
immediate uh sort of context as to like
where you are so today I think we're
going to really focus on this
entrepreneurial Journey that you've been
on over the last 10 years
and obviously one of the first key
Milestones was you won The Apprentice in
2012 so that meant that you got 250
grams worth of investment but then you
also became 50 partners with Alan sugar
um and your business was a recruitment
business
um so hyper recruitment Solutions is
what you started a business serving the
life science Market
um and that's the the journey you've
been on over the last decade building
that business and from what you shared
to me the last sort of financial uh year
and sort of uh and then around where you
are today you've got 45 people in the
business today
um did 15 million pounds in Revenue
um last Financial year six percent of
that was perm 40 of that contract
um 80 of the business at the moment um
in terms of what you do and the clients
companies you serve the UK and then you
have 200 in EU just obviously we'll
touch on this but also um in the process
of taking your your service and
proposition to the US which is exciting
you got the main Hub in uh Loughton
uh office in Manchester as well you've
got a network in Edinburgh and I think
that's that's about it yeah you've
covered a lot like are we done yeah
we're done but I said to you before that
there is no taboo topic with me really
just fire away at me and if it's awkward
and I squirm that's cool let's do it
okay sweet so first question that we
always like to start with which is the
million pound question in your opinion
what characteristics and traits do you
believe makeup are highly successful
recruitment in today's market so many
answers you're gonna get for this so so
many but
I've got two kind of outcomes here I
think first of all somebody who's really
really passionate about a space so
context for me as I study biochemistry
at Cardiff University I'm a scientist by
academics so why do I recruit the life
sciences well I study the field that I
really thought I could make a difference
I was just a shocking scientist but I
like to talk so speaking to people about
science made sense so the context there
for me is someone is passionate about a
field they'll go above and beyond so
when you're bringing people into your
company you want people for your
business particularly at the front end
to go above and beyond in what they do
so if they really really care about
something you don't need to be qualified
in it but if they do care about it
intimately they will succeed the second
thing has to be energy I don't care and
I say this to people Angela I don't care
how smart you are I don't care how
knowledgeable you are about a field if
you are as dull as dishwater you are
never going to survive in recruitment
because people not just buy from people
people work with people people interact
so for me pass in a topic will really
make a big difference secondly a whole
bunch of energy because you know what
lightens up the room lightens up a
Marketplace
um you can make anything from energy
long way what you can't do is bore
people to death and recruit them and um
there are a lot of people who do that
unfortunately
so look let's get straight into this so
um I was watching different interviews
that you've done in these things let's
just let's just talk about the The
Apprentice part of this journey because
it's clearly an important part of the
journey right so firstly what I wanted
to ask you uh is so I used to probably
when you uh was on the show was when I
actually liked it The Apprentice because
I feel like now it's just I the reason
why I liked it was I feel like you
actually got genuine insight into
business and people being put into
business situations and I felt like I
actually used to learn from it whereas
now I feel like it's way more reality uh
TV you know um how can we provide as
much entertainment as possible make
people feel look stupid or whatever so I
was just curious firstly like how much
of the Apprentice is actually like real
compared to it being scripted there's
zero script I think that's one thing I
will say it's not scripted reality So
like um my office is in Loughton
Loughton is one of the homes of Towery
land right so you've got a lot of
scripted reality in and around where my
office is but The Apprentice isn't
scripted in any way at no stage if they
said push a bit harder in this direction
talk about this topic or um don't get me
wrong it's production you might have
conversation they say look can you say
that again but make it shorter so they
are producing a program at the same time
but everything if I go back and um I
haven't actually rewatched it since it
was on TV and to be honest when it was
on TV I was also in the process of
getting married so I was so consumed
with personal affairs how are you my
wife and I looking to kind of say I do
to each other and we are still together
now which is great 10 plus years on
um when I watched it back there was
nothing that I said that I'm not I can't
believe I said that because they asked
me to or there was a few occasions I
can't believe I said that because I'm a
complete idiot on occasions but it's not
scripted
um but let's kind of like be true to the
word like the program still is for TV
it's still an entertainment program so
again going back to my what makes a good
recruitment concern if you get a Dallas
dishwater person in recruitment they
don't work if you get a dollar's
dishwater person on The Apprentice it
doesn't make good entertainment so there
is a a bit of a catch-22 for them they
need it to be interesting to kind of get
people to watch but they also need it to
be as business focused and orientated as
possible and I I hold nothing back I I
believe that I was cast because I had
business credentials a good business
idea and a background in recruitment but
I believe ours cast as a character not
as necessarily this is the guy who will
win The Apprentice yeah let's talk about
his character because mate I watched
your audition tape on YouTube wild mate
so this is where like this I just wanna
I have a specific question around this
but I understand like you just said
you've got to play the game right look
I've spoke to one or two people that
apply for The Apprentice and like you
have to go through rounds and rounds of
interviews right or like different
assessment things
um so I understand that you have to give
sound bites you have to like you know do
things in the moment but your audition
tape mate in 2012 where you said things
like I'm the reflection of perfection
yeah other people look at me and want to
be me like I just thought I was wild so
the the question that I had for you was
understand the context of where you're
doing that yeah but my question is you
know we hear this sort of fake it until
you make it you had a track record of
being in recruitment for five plus years
for a reputable company
um but my question is like do you feel
like you have to have that level of
arrogance and self-belief before you
have the track record and evidence to go
no Ricky you are what you're saying you
are do you know what I mean like because
I feel like there's a fine balance there
there is a balance and do not fake it to
you make it is a saying that I've heard
a lot and I've believed on occasions and
not believed on occasions but I guess in
that environment they are trying to cast
people that aren't going to melt in
front of I don't know a pitch panel
they're not going to melt when all of a
sudden we could have a conversation okay
yes we are recording this but you all of
a sudden you've got I don't know 15
cameras following you around a camera
crew sound crew
um Runners all these different people
people looking after your kind of
personal affairs or whatever it might be
running around with you and in the back
of your mind you know that's going to be
televised they need to make sure people
can't melt at that point because if they
melt they can't make a program so I do
think they need to see that level of
confidence and when I look at the
process of the auditioning and there's
nothing wrong with this but we need to
remember there's two different people
that are in tune at different occasions
you've got business people interviewing
you for what you want to do and what you
can do and how commercially Savvy you
are and you've got production people
auditioning you for TV if that makes
sense so I guess
fake it till you make it if anything
playing the game was probably the right
thing from my side I switched on
whatever I needed to switch on based on
who I was in the room with and I do
believe they cast this kind of
over-the-top character that says things
like the reflection of perfection like
look don't get me wrong I say it with a
smile on my face because I find it
hilarious but if anyone um if anyone is
into their kind of pro wrestling um
they'll know that it was something I did
in the past and actually a reflection of
the Perfection is like a gimmick of a
character called Superstar Billy Graham
who Hulk Hogan basically imitate
emulated so he was like the original
Hulk Hogan it was one of his phrases
um and it goes on reflection of the
Perfection the number one selection
um the Tower of Power it goes on there's
a whole line of them I just chose the
bit that I'm like do you know what that
works for me so let's talk about the
wrestling then before we go into this
business Journey because I I absolutely
loved wrestling yeah when I was growing
up I thought it was absolute Mega
um I heard you say on an interview that
whilst you was
um interviewing or going through The
Apprentice process you also had a
process with WWE yeah you spot on your
research is pretty bloody good
um yeah so I I guess to give you an idea
so I was in the pro wrestling circuit
across the UK and Europe for about
probably in total just over 10 years
um so I was doing it a lot up until so I
did it prior to during my studies all
the way through my earlier recruitment
career and when I got The Apprentice
audition I had already had options to
try out for the what is now the WWE The
World Wrestling Entertainment and that's
and they only do that twice a year
um so I already knew Bookers across the
country and I'd already wrestled on
their kind of independent shows they're
like why don't you come over and try out
and I'm pretty sure it's in Liverpool at
the time and I remember looking at it
thinking well this is something I've
really wanted for a very long time and
to look at me now you wouldn't think I
wrestled but at the time I was really
into what I was doing yeah but he can
all sorts mate I've seen his videos wow
bleach Mohican with um not just that I
even put extensions on the bottom to
have a big mullet on the back of it so
they did some televised stuff and I
thought I put a mullet on so I look like
a hillbilly
um but I I had the auditions I remember
at the time thinking okay I've really
got a defining decision to make what I
did know is they normally audition you
at least twice um or sorry try out you
twice when it comes to wrestling I was
like me in May and they'll be back again
I think it's like September October so
that if if I was any good they liked it
and I backed myself but I'm not seven
foot tall in that 25 stone and that's
what they cast at the time I don't ask
me back in kind of September October to
try out a second time and I'm like you
know what even if it falls apart on The
Apprentice It's a little bit of a USP
that might give me a better shot next
time for the resting so I was like my
day job is more serious now I'm about to
get married and like the whole wrestling
thing I was like
got the gig back then it was 300 Days on
the Road throughout the world I'd never
have like time for a life and a wife and
all those things so
um yeah I loved it and I actually think
it really really helped me with the
auditioning and getting on the
apprentice and it's helped me in life
not that people would think that but um
at that moment I was like I know that I
want to get this business going and I
believe I can win it so I kind of at
that point mentally checked out of
wrestling that's kind of that that part
of me that's over but that part of me
that gave me a character and like a
larger than life personality I was able
to use to
um get the kind of the gig to be on the
apprentice and I was able to use
elements not being comfortable in the
room pitching in front of it well I've
been wrestling in front of several
thousand people like in in a pair of
pants basically so if you can do that
you can talk to a bunch of business
experts on some as far as I'm concerned
what is your signature move um I I had
about a thousand names it was actually a
wrestler back in the 90s called Dilo
Brown he did a move called um Sky High
okay um I called it the flatliner which
basically is a sit-down Power Bomb that
was mine and I like to do a Swanton
although I never landed it I always
intentionally said it looks good but I
don't need to land the thing so I'll
miss it every time yeah I was going to
ask you uh what are some of the things
you've taken from the wrestling world
into like your yeah you know
professional life whatever but I think
you've answered it there a lot I totally
see the the
um the translation of like what you can
take from that environment and being
that because yeah courage confidence
being out of your comfort zone
communicating like that there's a lot of
things you have to do to be a good
wrestler a wrestling storytelling it's
good versus evil there's always at the
end of it whether it's on a night or
over a series there's always a positive
outcome so every wrestler's part is to
get the best story across whether you're
good whether you're bad and
um it's about identifying how you work
with other people that are very
different to you to get a good outcome
and how to entertain a group of people
watching it and on occasions if it was
televised trying to not work the room
worker camera so that you could position
it in a way that it transcended the TV
so I think it really really helped them
that the ability to to be thinking about
storytelling I think and everything we
do these days marketing everything is
storytelling yeah totally wrestling
that's all it is it's a story every
single time so let's just start then I
want to talk about the the last decade
so how what was like the the setup with
uh Alan sugar then so firstly hazy has
he when he partnered with you uh had he
ever invested in the recruitment
business before and then two like what
was the actual setup was it you got the
investment then on a monthly basis
you're having a board meeting
a board meeting like yeah what was the
actual setup I'd say the setup some
people might think it's bigger or more
dreamy than it could be but the setup is
no different than getting a third-party
company to invest into your business and
then you think they're thinking I'm
gonna go and work in a wee work office
it's really no different to that I got
bank accounts things are set up we had
to go for the legal side of shareholding
but once that was done no different to
setting up a company online and putting
your legalities between you and a
business partner
um the money was there in the bank and
it was really down to me that they they
have never Lord sugar and his kind of
Associates around them they'd never been
in the services industry they've always
been product the closest to Services
would have been property
um which is where most of the wealth is
these days rather than product but today
Lord sugar is a product man I was the
first service industry decided to get
involved in so for him it was a bit
alien for me it was like well actually
I've been doing this for a while this is
my kind of baby I even studied in this
era so I kind of know what I'm doing so
really it's no different to getting
either a company that will give you
money and there's loads I won't name
them but there's loads of them around
that'll be like well we'll take a share
of your business but we'll give you the
website we'll give you the CRM we'll
give you the access to financing from an
invoice discount and for whoever it's
almost no different to that it's like
going to one of those companies and they
take a share of your business but
ultimately you're running it from that
point and um I had a choice where the
hell I wanted to set it up really as
close as possible and I was living on
the south coast of the UK between
Portsmouth and Southampton at the time I
thought well do you know what getting
the investment's one thing but he also
had some like spare space in one of his
offices where he was based and I'm like
actually that's no different to getting
a I paid a service charge for the office
like her desk and with the use of the
facility just like you would doing like
a wee work or something so for me I was
like yeah the investment's one thing but
being around where that investor is
someone like Alan sugar there must be
something there I could learn despite
the services English that would help me
personally and professionally so going
into his offices gave me the ability to
see him more often if needed now don't
get me wrong he can't tell me how to win
a job in recruitment how to qualify a
job and how to take a candidate for a
process and do ABC selling kind of thing
in recruitment terms but I did have his
financial advisors around and I I use
them as my accountancy so I paid them
for their service so really
um it's no different to just setting up
on your own beer he's obviously got a
big name behind you which can sound
impressive so for me it was good because
it gave me a bit of financial
credibility that when I was setting up
and trying to put in supplier agreements
they were like okay you've got a
billionaire backer it's been quite we
know you've got the money Ricky so we
will let you pay per month rather than
your lump Summit now for the first 12
months so I can manage my cash a bit
better yeah because that was where I
just wanted to just uh give him that
first question on that and you you sort
of violence there's a lot to be fair
which I I didn't want to assume
um but I sort of did uh in terms of like
do you feel like what's actually been
more valuable besides getting the
resources infrastructure it's actually
been more around like the brand I feel
like I don't know that's outside looking
in it seems like you really do have done
a good job of leveraging his brand or
like the brat like that the brand
element rather than
um okay Ricky we're going to really help
you come up with a business development
strategy that's going to help you sign
30 great Live Science they gave me none
of that they couldn't give me anything
from a
um recruitment perspective so I I go to
different recruitment membership and
part of things that I like to network I
like to see how other people that are
running businesses doing things what the
pains which they couldn't do any of that
with me I mean brand probably the brand
of
um I've got a serious backer means that
we're a serious company which means I
don't know if we're trying to go drive
up our contract side of the business we
know we've got the financial security
that we could take a large project of
contractors and if we payroll con we're
going to be able to pay on to the end of
the assignment rather than a startup
business just you are such an anomaly
but what the brand couldn't do is win me
any business not not just show me how to
win business but I just got no
background in the pharmacy who's got
life science sector so there's no client
sitting there thinking hello Ricky we've
been waiting for you and there's some
very good players in what I do so it was
purely maybe the stigma where I think it
probably helped at the front end is
trying to acquire when I say acquire
it's probably a bit harsh trying to look
for hiring good talent in the business
that people are they've got a decent
backing let's give it a go
um so it gave us a bit of a USP versus
being being like one of the many
recruitment companies in the ocean of
London it gave us a bit of a that could
be an interesting firm at the same time
speaking honestly um it also made it a
bit of a headache because I got a lot of
interest at the start of people say I'd
love to work with you and everyone just
wanted to be involved because of Lord
sugar or because of the apprentice and
I'm like do you know what as much as
I'll always talk about the apprentice
and if I hadn't been on it I'd have
spoken to anyone was on it because I
watched the show I don't want to be
known as Ricky from The Apprentice It's
never been my objective so for me as
soon as people come into this I love The
Apprentice blah blah I want to work for
you I'm like I don't know if that's the
person I want to work a bit of a red
flag so I almost had to kind of filter
out anyone who was like all over The
Apprentice like kind of like Fanning The
Apprentice a little bit and almost be
real to people saying you do know a
little sugar obviously we've moved out
of his stuff we're only there for a year
until I've took my own premises and
things he's not in my office he's an
investor he's not employed by the
business he is a shareholder who
invested 10 years ago so it's not going
to be your best mate on Twitter and have
a chat with you about Spurs every day
and I I almost have been first in
people's bubbles more than I wasn't yeah
so final thing on this then just curious
if we can keep it real have you found
yourself then thinking do I regret
giving 50 of my business with that being
the case you know the things you
describing you've been really honest
with us on where you saw the benefit
where maybe they didn't add as much
value so do you ever find yourself
thinking you know what I could have done
this on my own I've known 100 of this
this company I get asked it quite a lot
um
I'll give you different parts that
answer the front end I could have done
it without it I was always going to do
the business and I think that's why they
were quite interested in in making the
um the investment because they knew I
was serious whereas some people in The
Apprentice and probably more as the
years have gone on aren't as genuine
about wanting to run a business they're
probably genuine about being on TV and
you're always going to get some of that
for a TV production but I was genuine
about doing and I was very clear to say
I'm doing this with or without you so
like not in a non-arrogant way but this
is what I built my career to do
um so I was going to do it and it would
have taken me longer taking me a lot
longer do I regret giving absolutely not
no
um if I was doing it if I sold HRS now
and did it again tomorrow no way on
Earth would I do it this way of course I
wouldn't I've now got 11 12 years more
experience than I did then I wouldn't
need that but at the time it was right
for me I was an employee of a business I
hadn't run an independent company I
hadn't set up an independent company at
the time it was right for me and as
somebody who's invested into things
myself it's an Investor's right to put
the money in and take the gamble if
there's an upside you're going to cream
it at that point but more often than not
there's a downside so
um I never sit here on a yearly basis
thinking oh we've drawn some dividends
this year and because he's got a lot of
money out of that and like he's done
nothing for that
um and people say to him all day long
you must resent it I'm like I don't
because he took the shot on me and he
took the chance and that's an Investor's
prerogative do I
um have I given some serious money away
to him as a result yeah I have but you
know what that was the that was the deal
that was broken at the front end
um I wouldn't do if I went back in time
I'd have made the same call that
probably says I don't regret it but if I
was making that call again today with
the knowledge I've now got I wouldn't
need to do that yeah and I appreciate
you being honest there so
right so let's go into this business
journey and I have just one personal
question which I'm personally just
really curious about and then we'll get
into scaling what you've learned
challenges so
obviously I I think I heard you say
um just off the cuff like oh everyone
wants to get into Life Sciences now it's
way more competitive right so just a
personal question this wherever you
stand wherever your stance is on vaccine
no vaccine or whatever thing that I'm
really curious about is just like
clearly um in history some of the
biggest lawsuits and settlements have
been with Pharma companies from farmer
companies right so I think where we've
all experienced this this crazy part of
um you know history together where
almost you had to put our trust in these
big companies that historically may not
have always been trustworthy like coming
out the other side of it have have they
gained have you found that people like
want to get more into the industry has
their credibility as an industry being
tainted I'm just super curious on like
life sciences outside coming out the
other side of covert has their
reputation stuff been really tainted and
has that ever I don't know yeah I'm just
super curious on that I think there's
two sides to it the life science side I
think
there's the Dark Side of it which is the
big corporate side of money making and
let's let's not kind of hold anything
back these are commercial companies
trying to make money yeah they normally
start with really passionate scientists
with a great life-changing or saving
kind of idea whether it be a technology
or a medicine that eventually gets
purchased by a big company
because it costs
over a billion pounds to get a drug to
Market it takes nearly 15 years and
every 10 000 ideas that come up only one
get to the market so it has to be a
commercially Cutthroat environment in
order to get that drug to Marketplace
when it's hugely competitive the big
companies it's always going to be what
makes them the most money despite them
in my opinion telling you it's all about
the patient it is going to be a
commercial thing the small business is
not I think what's happened over the
last kind of handful of years with covid
and the vaccine it's probably put it
more in the front of people's mind that
wow do you know what and what was really
impressive is how a vaccine got out so
quickly when you've already heard me
saying it can take up to 15 years for a
drug to be bought to Market so it was
the first time that you really saw all
of these big corporates and their supply
chain to people who contract manufacture
people who do certain parts of research
or they might make things that the drug
goes in it's the first time you really
saw such collaboration between all these
business it was almost like forget the
commercials like don't get me wrong they
still didn't forget it business business
has made a lot of money in that period
but it was more about how on Earth do we
save mankind
um or humankind at this time so you saw
lots more open collaboration between
businesses and not worrying about IEP
and bits and pieces so
um it's put at the Forefront of people's
minds is it still a difficult industry
of course it is you're going to have one
side of it which is about patience and
it's kind of where I come from that as a
scientist who wanted to help the world
but was rubbish at science I'm good at
talking to scientists about what they're
doing and I'm really passionate about it
so for me if I get the right person to
the right job they can actually drive a
medicine to a patient it makes a
difference that's what gets me out of
bed and that's how I drive my business
um so there will always be those people
in life sciences but there's also the
other people in life sciences who just
want to make the big bucks just want to
kind of make as much as they can and you
know what there's those companies that
sometimes a new idea come to the
Forefront they'll buy it and mothball it
because it competes with the product
that's already making the money so
um it is incredibly commercially Savvy
and
because it's in the front of our minds
and there's been a fair amount of jobs
in that field through covert and
thereafter it's become more attractive
for people to want to be a service
provider to that industry no yeah for
sure I just think I mean the whole
separate topic but one of the things I
always can't get my head around is uh
the fact that like these uh companies
can advertise their drugs in America
like that actually like that actually
baffles me well it's it's not just that
when you see it and I go to the US in a
few weeks when you see it
um it's mad because at the end you see
the disclaimer of Health like like risks
and that is the reality any drug has a
risk right and if you think of like the
vaccine I remember there was all the
Uproar about a certain percentage of
people having respiratory problems as a
result of taking the vaccine drug
um ironically the amount of people who
had that percentage-wise is fewer than
the amount of people that might have
issues with the normal drug it's just
the world was running a clinical trial
so there was more of them but the
percentage of them was fewer but you're
right going to America I love the
commercials in America it's it literally
if you if you don't want to leave the
house you had a hard time live in
America because it won't let you out of
the house
so let's talk about this uh this grown
National criminal business so where I
wanted to start was obviously you're
around 45 heads at the moment what I
picked up on when I was just watching
some videos and uh stuff was the way
that you described you hired people was
through academies yeah which I found
really interesting so obviously all I do
is speak to recruit owners uh that
typically do want to grow excuse me
about training and getting the most out
of their people
um and oftentimes I will hear companies
aspire to they'd love to run an academy
or get to the point where they're
running an academy so I guess my first
question was obviously if we are all
going to successfully scale our business
then we need to get good at hiring
people and getting them up to speed
quickly and getting the most out of
people and reducing our attrition rate
so I guess my first question is how
would you what was your first version of
an academy and and what like yeah what
did that actually look like and where
can people start
um in having actually academies in their
business that helps them get more out of
their people good question and if I look
at growth I mean we're 10 years old so
we haven't had meteoric growth in the
grand scheme of regret there's some
businesses that started in the last 18
months that are probably already double
triple the size of us but their way of
growth is different it's like throw a
load of people in don't worry about the
bottom line and then try and get a
market share over a number of period
because they're they're run by probably
VCS with a lot of cash whereas I set up
in a more organic way
um my first Academy so I started
technically I rocked up
um and start day one was July 20 2012.
we didn't launch till October but I ran
my first Academy in November December
like I'd only been running for four or
five months we hadn't even started
really doing much work with clients
because I was getting systems and
whatever put in place so I ran my first
academies when I only had three
employees in my Workforce me my
brother-in-law doing some data mining
helped me build some CRM stuff and a
recruiter that I had looked in the
marketplace and reached out and I
thought brilliantly knows life science
I'll bring him in so I ran my first one
a couple of months into the business and
hired my first Academy it was only three
people in in January 2013 so that my
business is only six months old there
are only three of us and I hired an
Academy of three and double my head
count I know small numbers but
um you don't need to be old a mature
business or a big infrastructure to run
an academy I mean for me it was the
assessment days I structured them in a
way that I thought I could understand
the type of character I'm looking for
and when I say academies I'm talking
about training academies in the
organization as opposed to lots of
experienced recruiters coming into an
academy if that makes sense of getting
people up and running them really it was
just building the map of how I want to
develop them I think if you're going to
bring people in your business
and you've got no idea how you're going
to support and develop them
you're going to struggle and if you if
your approach is go and high load of
experienced people who know stuff and
they know what they're doing you'll end
up with a bit of a mismatch of a culture
of people doing you'll find a bunch of
people that might be LinkedIn recruiters
then you find a bunch of people who are
old school recruits and they find a
bunch of people who don't know what the
hell they are but they like the sound of
that but might want to do a bit of that
and you'll end up with loads of
different so really for me it was map
out what that first 12-month Journey
looks like find a way that I can do it
when actually my resource is me only one
other experienced con and the other
person's a data Miner how do we get
those people up and running
um it was hard but the business I worked
for were quite structured with how they
developed people and they were like
Milestones that will train you this in
month one month two so I kind of Built
My Own program of thinking what's going
to be important I'm going to be winning
a lot of business I back myself doing a
lot of business first years so to start
with the key skills for me were how can
I get them to help me service this
business as quickly as they can then get
them in there and then within a few
months how do I show them to be more
um
follow up their leads look at where
they've got a job what other what other
calls can you make from cool so um it's
just sitting down and looking at how you
want your business to grow maybe for the
next two years what that looks like the
people you need to get there and how
many you might need and then what
support you need to give to get them
there but it's not rocket science it
just takes a little bit of sitting down
and mapping out and planning just like
every day of recruitment you should come
into a day knowing what the plan is for
the day
um so I still believe in them and I
actually hosted an assessment day
yesterday for this year's intake and I'm
still involved in those assessment days
the way we assess them hasn't actually
changed that much we now use technology
to then remove unconscious bias and we
can all the interview panel can put in
information and it will give like an
algorithm to score them without us
making I can go for a bit of them so
I'll hire them which is probably a bit
more what it was like back in the day so
I don't think people need to overly
complicate it if you want to scale
look to bring people in who believe in
what you stand for share the values
you've got and can recruit in a similar
way or the way you want it to work
because you might think the way of
recruiting is different to what you did
therefore that's what you want to train
and make sure everybody is on is kind of
singing off the same him she because if
everyone does different things you're
never going to be a business hey
everyone a real quick one from me this
podcast would not be possible without
our amazing podcast Partners Vin cherry
and Source breaker because you listen to
this podcast you're able to get your
hands on exclusive savings on both of
these award-winning products if you're a
growing recruitment business you have to
check out vincere who are an all-in-one
operating system for your growing
recruitment business with Source breaker
if you want to make sure that all of
your recruiters have the best tools on
the market to stand out and beat their
competition then you have to check out
Source breaker use the link in the show
notes in the comments below and you'll
be able to get yourself exclusive
savings on these amazing products so
okay cool right so just specifically
around the academy then really quickly
okay
um I guess firstly obviously from where
I say it the main positive right is that
you've hired three people at the same
time which means you've got a really
great opportunity to in three months
time have three people at the same sort
of level yeah whereas as you know
um if you've spoken to other Founders
and stuff like a lot of companies uh if
they hire in ones and twos or whatever
they have to do the exact same thing
with someone for
um four weeks ago and then do it again
another four weeks right the major
positive that I see is that you're
making the most out of your time you
know so you can get people up to speed
so specific question on the uh Academy
there is what are the sort of core
um things that you look at that you'll
keep an eye on in those early days for
you to go you know what this person is
going to work out or not like what are
some of the early early sort of um data
points that you look at I'm sure this
has evolved over time what are the key
things for you to go you know what not
sure this person's right you know what
some of the key things you look for if
we take the obvious like non-recruitment
things that any employee should be
looking at punctuality time keeping
um are they turning up at 8 29 for an 8
30 day and then going to get the
breakfast run their jacket on at 5 29 to
get out the door at five other than
those obvious things which I think is
really important at the front end
because you want to see people are
prepared to do it not block watch and
get in and get out for me it was very
quite clear I'm going to show them how
to interview candidates at the front end
I'm going to put them through some
training I'm going to run some role
plays I'm going to listen to what
they're doing to try and see how they're
going just really we we spent and it's
not maybe as long as this but not far
off the First full month was just
completely open interviewing candidates
um not necessarily on behalf of a role
just open interviewing firstly to
refresh our system but secondly to give
them the confidence of the marketplace
they're working in to understand the
terminology of the candidates be to turn
themselves into a detective which is
what I say all the time which is ask
curious questions to your candidates and
if you don't know something can you tell
me a bit more about them and and we'd
set them a parameter we want you in that
week to be speaking to x amount of
people and have one amount of phone time
and like don't get me wrong phone Tom's
just an early stage precursor for me it
shows that people can be busy but it
certainly you can have 20 hours a week
of one rubbish call just to the talking
clock and loads of like thousands of
course some so for me it's very much at
the front end I need you to get through
lots of people quickly I need you to
learn very quickly and I'm going to
listen into the calls I'm going to give
real-time feedback I'm going to look at
the dates you put in the system so
everything is audited all the notes go
into the system I can look it there and
I'll run a report each day to see have
they left messages they can get through
to people if they send text to catch up
on people they emailed them I can look
at that and say I can see here that
actually most of you Works outbound
which is correct at start but no one's
coming back to you so let's listen to
the quality of a left message let's look
at the quality of the text message and
say let's just look at some basic things
which is really basic I'm not even being
Advanced here but what I can determine
in that first month is if the person's
got the commitment to achieve a volume
Target because they don't know what good
looks like in the first month or you can
judge them on is quantity really and
then you change that quantity from I
don't need you loads of calls it needs
to be loaded the good the right good
calls
um so really for me quantity to begin
with to see if they can have commitment
to a Target can they hit that Target if
they're behind that Target what are they
going to do to make that work are they
gonna go out the door at 5 30 the end of
the day or are they going to put a
little bit more in to try and beat that
Target are they going to going through
the notes is the quality of the notes
looking good so for me what I'm looking
at the front end is the ability for them
to
strive to hit a Target and go beyond not
stop when they get there and the ability
to keep going I think that's really if
they can't do those things they never
work never ever work because you'll
always be in a position of saying oh can
you do a little bit more I mean I don't
want to be speaking to anyone after the
first six months really and ever saying
you should be doing a bit more work than
you are people should have got it by
then and they should be able to do that
and the first month is a real indicator
of
urgency and commitment to what they're
doing and if they can't achieve some of
the basic parameters I am quite fit it's
like can I help you and if I can I'll
give you more time if I can't help it
because you're just lazy then I'm not
going to waste my time and I've probably
as the years have gone on made those
decisions a lot quicker than I did in
the front end so then and then just
because I feel like this is quite
fundamental to grow and like the fact
that you're still doing them yeah so
let's just talk to them about the
assessment side because I think people
will be interested in that so you said
you had one yesterday like what does
that actually consist of you have people
in your head office come there so I'm
assuming you have someone try and get as
many people as possible there's so
certain parameters that you want these
people to have they get invited to this
assessment center then are they going to
get some sort of talk from a relevant
person saying this is what we are this
is what we're about this is what we're
doing and then what they put get put
through a series of activities to them
to a point where they're then going to
get booked into final interview I don't
know talk to us a bit about how these
assessments look so once they're there
so that I'll have a TA person who's
taking the responsibility for sourcing
interviewing asking to think about
things come back almost through the
first stages done before them but when
they're there I'll run them through and
it's yesterday if I look at it it was a
group of eight people that we've had in
all this year's graduates I think two
weren't grads don't have to be a grab
that had relevant experience all have
worked while at Uni outside of work
either through Summers or in the
evenings because I've I've done it a few
times I never want to be the first
person other than someone's mum or dad
to tell them what to do so for me doing
I don't care what your job is doing a
job that's not like for your parents to
me is really important because I don't
want to be like it's not a parental
relationship and that's not what I'm
looking to try and build
um so we'll have them doing some like we
get them doing it like a Dragon's Den
exercise where they come together come
up with an idea as a group and Pitch it
back to us as a panel so you can see how
they communicate how they structure and
how they think on their feet when we
challenge them
um we used to we don't anymore get to
prepare a presentation beforehand and
what recruitment is and why
um being honest
um the exercise was there to a level of
commitment if they can't be bothered to
do a presentation why can I be bothered
to injure them type mindset but we were
finding that
um when some grads had a lot of
opportunities maybe the presentation was
being a bit of a blocker so and they
just presented the same thing every time
we get them doing a um almost a role
play exercise where they're looking at
CVS and they're trying to assess them
and then they were literally either go
into a room based on the setup of the
day
or they'll phone into an experienced
consultant wow and try and represent
which candidate of the selection of six
is the best candidate for the job and
we're honest to say this is like the
dirtiest side of recruitment because
actually looking for the personality in
a culture you can't do that today you
can look at words and receiving words in
a job description but just to see how
their brain works a little bit we then
we'll get them doing like an icebreaker
as a room but they always start with the
exception to pretty much maybe two of
the assessment days in the Ten Years
with me opening talking about the
business talking about what we're
looking for in our recruiters just
showing them that it's really important
to me that and being humble to them to
say our business can't grow unless we
bring good people in training you come
with us in the journey because we're not
going to hire loads of 20 years
recruitment veterans we're looking to
hire the next generation of recruiters
who can grow in my business and grow my
business and final two things then uh
what's the typical like conversion rate
of like you know number of people that
come in number of people that you offer
it's changed over the years so
um premium pandemic I would say
um
short-term success for me is they get to
the first 12 months they get to the year
Milestone next success really is two
years onwards and if I went back in the
past we were probably looking at about a
60 probably more close to 70 percent one
year pass rate if that makes sense of
them so if you hired three two would
work out
um and then if you'd hired three then if
you get to the second year you would
probably find that sixty percent it's
probably come down to about
40 so those numbers look crude but I
could have hardened a cat if I used my
first ever Academy on my first three
that I hired
um
two got to the end of the first year one
got the end of the second year and that
one it got 10 to the second year is
still with me today he's been there for
10 years and set up my Edinburgh office
and um it's been an incredible member of
the workforce and did really well when
those Academy numbers go a bit bigger
you get more than one for it but I
always look at it if you're bringing in
a trainee not everyone I mean we all
hear that no one chooses recruitment
like back in the day particularly you
still hear that now I fell into it as I
did as well
um but you have to accept that there's a
level of Dropout because some people
just won't like it or they won't be able
to get up to the standard or actually
life gets in the way
um that prop got worse during the
pandemic because the first year we kind
of said well we're not going to hire any
right now because we're not quite sure
what our head count is then we kind of
got back but that 60 kind of two out of
three probably come one out of three in
the first year as a result of the
pandemic because actually if you look at
what I was then having to hire from
pre-pandemic I was trying to hide the
best of the best anywhere in the country
and I'd get to relocate to the area
they're join an academy so they've got a
community of people to work with become
a bit stickier to the business and
there's friends that they can build and
actually they can socialize with them
they don't have loads of other friends
around pandemic come along no one would
move anymore
um it then become actually who can I
hire that's within like 30 45 minutes of
the office now so that changed the the
pool of people we could hire and what
what I found with that pool of talent is
when it got a little bit difficult
because most of them were living at home
with mum and dad since it's got
difficult they just gave up I found that
that but that and I don't put that down
to a generational thing I put that down
to we were only hiring from a local
demographic because we had to evolve and
now we've gone back to hiring best of
the best from wherever we can find them
across the country and we're already
seeing our last Academy from last year
has already got back to the numbers that
we were at before I think we hired
um six we've got five of them still
um almost a year on so actually that's
probably slightly better and um so it
has changed um but for me
if you're higher and won't expect them
to work you have to work on a level of
probability that people won't work they
don't like you you don't like what
they're doing or life gets in the way so
you have to I'm not going to call it a
numbers game but you have to consider
that
um you're better to hire more than one
at a time unless it's just one Gap and
you're absolutely confident in who they
are and you have a good idea about them
no I really appreciate it being honest
there because I think again obviously
the huge Pro of that approach uh just
from the founder perspective is you you
invest all that time and you have more
chance of more people working out yeah
because you're just scaling your time
really do you know I mean the fact that
you can spend however much time that you
spend yesterday I'm sure that when you
do these consistently you don't do as
much prep anymore you know what you need
to be said it's a bit more like
clockwork
um but that means like you've spent that
time last night and you have the
opportunity to hire you know a good
cohort of people whereas obviously a lot
of uh companies they invest the exact
same time and they might hire one person
you know and then they might not work
out and then we're back hiring again so
I'll be appreciate you being honest with
that and I think that would be really
interesting and useful for people
listening who who particularly want to
grow their business well you've said it
is optimizing time if I did it again in
the front you tell yourself I haven't
got the time to support three people but
actually if you support three people at
the same time you're almost supporting
one person
um and you maximize your chance of
success from it this year we are still
doing academies we we went for a period
of only doing enrollments for academies
now we've kind of evolved where actually
we're doing key academies at the
beginning of the year and we were having
to put on more academies to offset maybe
drop out if we wanted growth now I'm
saying well let's not do Dropout
academies not that I ever worded it like
that yeah that's what they were
um and then we will plug in some ones
and twos at a time but we have the scale
to do that now where is it the front end
I wouldn't have had the scale to do that
at all and then yeah obviously we've
spoken about from the business owner
perspective but then also if you think
about it I don't know the stats but I'd
be confident that if you start a new job
with other people at the same time
there's Pro hopefully more chance that
you are going to be successful but over
also you might enjoy it more because
like you know you're on the same
Learning Journey at the same time like
you said there's more chance of building
um friends and those connections so I I
think also and also look let's be honest
I hire three people I'm gonna see very
quickly who's good out of that
free because you can you can compare
yeah you know whereas if you have one
person you've got no one's
compare them to you know what I mean
Community is the word I use we're we're
bringing in the people to build their
own community and ideally they all go
into different I might have someone go
to manage to someone do whatever now
we're starting to do the year someone
could go to the eventually those people
will build the network of your business
internally because they all know each
other they went on that Journey
positives are communities I find they're
stickier as a Workforce because they
want to fight for it for each other and
they'll prop each other up when it's
difficult negatives are if you get a bit
of toxicity and that it then spoils the
whole kind of dinner if that makes sense
so we've seen both of it and we have had
pockets of the wrong persons in there
getting into the minds of the others and
when they're getting a tough time
they're basically telling others oh you
know there's a problem here and then
they almost poison everyone else so if
you're doing it just make sure if you're
bringing academies in that you've tested
as much as you can of the type of
character you want in your business and
um if you see some of the negative
traits make a quick decision on them
could be for the right reasons
challenges Outsider it could just be
they've got a chip on their bloody
shoulder and you know that chip becomes
your chip and it causes you problems of
the rest of your Academy so do them they
are brilliant they're the best thing
that I've ever done in terms of hiring
and to grow a business and I would do it
again if I started tomorrow morning just
be absolutely crucial that you're
getting the right ones or One Bad Apple
ruins it all
so 10 years in business long time yeah
too long I feel like you know we're with
that long I can only imagine that you
you just find yourself Reinventing you
know the business to go through
different seasons of that business but I
guess let's just start you you've you've
been really honest throughout this so I
wanted to just ask you in the if we were
to take a bit of a step back because it
was 10 it was 10 years like you know
um from when I looked like seven or
eight months ago you hit that 10-year
Mark yeah what would you say were one or
two of the biggest mistakes you made
um biggest mistake I think I've made
before and I have repeated and there's
occasions where I could do it as well is
how would I put it in the in the right
possible way is given too much benefit
of Doubt there are the occasions where
your kind of radar your recruitment
radar I think someone in my Workforce
called it their Spidey sensors that you
just get a feeling and the feeling isn't
sometimes great and you're like a
problem but I don't know what the
problem is and then I thought well I
can't see it I don't want to make it
look as a conspiracy theory going on I
don't I don't trust people and I haven't
acted on that I think at the front end
when you're hiring people you will ever
on to work it's my baby I hire the right
people I only want to work I'm a recruit
and come how can I make wrong hires we
go through all of it
um and I've wheeled people to work and
then I'm like they've just taken my
energy away from me it's not they've
been either they've ended up being
really boring they've been mood hoof and
I'm like as soon as you take my energy
from me you ruin me so take my energy
your peril because I I've got no
interest in your business you're in my
business but given that will and willing
them along and almost doing more for
them than they do for themselves is a
problem giving people too much benefit
of the doubt benefit the doubt is fair I
think we've got to treat people like
human beings and have a level of trust
even if it's not necessarily been built
you have to you hired someone you
trusted them as far as I'm concerned but
the minute the trust is either
jeopardized or you feel like
um it's all one-sided you have to make a
call and I've I've kept hold of people
on occasions for two too long and I've
always said it I would I would remove or
find a way to to politely say it's come
to an end my best biller if they were a
problem there have been occasions where
I probably haven't got to that decision
quick enough and I'm sharper at doing
that now which can sometimes make me
come across a little bit more mercenary
than maybe 10 years ago but that's
because over the last few years when the
pandemics come along and I've had to
manage a Workforce that carer
um as we all have we've had to look
after ourselves during covid and people
have looked after themselves more than
they've looked after maybe where they
are that I've had to make decisions for
the greater good and the benefit and
I've probably realized more on those
years that you know people can waste
time but what they're actually doing is
wasting my money and wasting my
opportunity for growth or and this is
what I say with The Apprentice sometimes
you get someone in the final who's a
complete bloody Joker and I'm like
you've just taken someone else's
opportunity to be in that final that's
what someone's doing in your business
if they are not taking it seriously and
giving it all they are taking someone
else's opportunity that'll help you to
grow that so I'm sharper at that now but
that mistake I've made again and again
and again because I like to think I'm a
decent guy and I'm not saying I've
become more I know it's bitter and
twisted but I've become sharper at it
and I'd always say you're hiring higher
fail fast let people make mistakes
that's fine as long as they learn from
the mistakes but if it's failing fail
fast and it took me too long to realize
that and I appreciate you sharing that I
think a lot of people resonate with that
so
lost Financial year revenue is 15
million yeah what do you think have been
some of the like core principles that
have enabled you guys to get to those
sorts of levels like what have been some
of the things you've really doubled down
on made good decisions on yeah what are
some of the the principles to to get
into those sorts of performance levels I
think first I mean as a number it's I
mean revenue is always vanity right it's
profitable
um and there are much bigger numbers
because we've been more perm than Contra
but that's change and that's what's kind
of got us going forward now
um some of the principles for me are
always it was it was the reason I
started the business it's the reason why
on occasions I've had to part companies
of people in the business but it's what
I stand for I stand for supporting an
industry that changes lives you heard it
at the front end of this and I'll always
say
um I work in a life-changing industry
and tongue-in-cheek I've caught my
Workforce Life Changes on time and time
again
um as soon as anything has almost
jeopardized that I I were making this
decision for commercial gain not because
of what we stand for or someone in my
business doesn't care about what I stand
for they just care about the commercials
um is the reason your business become
confused and have a problem so double
down and always remaining true to what
the business stands for and making
decisions with people who aren't aligned
with the value of what you stand from
the vision and being firm with them
despite them being maybe profit
generating
um I think that's really important
because you cannot grow a business that
doesn't have a purpose and you cannot
grow a business that doesn't have a
really cohesive culture
um and I think there's been a few
occasions I felt the culture getting a
little bit contradicted because of I
don't know other leaders other
individuals that didn't buy into it like
they used to and I'm like and I've
almost on occasions said to myself well
like have I changed no what the only
message that's changing people are
confused is what they're hearing from
other people not from me so I think
double Downing on what you stand for and
staying true to that and if what you
stand for changes be honest about that
telling people so I think that thing
that the leadership of who you are what
you're doing I think has to be
absolutely on point not Challenge and if
it's challenge find a way to understand
it and to change it I think that's
really really important and again that
just comes down onto getting the right
people in your business to keep
understanding that and seeing that and
I've had challenges over the years where
I started the business doing 100 of my
time recruiting
um and that percentage of time
recruiting that I absolutely love doing
has reduced is the businesses got bigger
and I've almost how do people realize
I'm still a good recruiter at what I'm
doing in this occasions where I'll jump
back in and do things and help people
and listen to things and do and I'm
working a couple of projects at the
moment I can humbly say that I
understand being in the business stops
you being on the business and therefore
you can't grow the business but there
are occasions where you just need to if
you're a star player you need to show
people how how the game can be done so
just really remaining true to what you
stand for okay let me ask you this then
speak to a lot of recruitment Founders
that struggle to get past the 15 20 Head
Mark most of the UK recruitment industry
are sort of under 10 heads so how
different did your business look at 20
heads compared to you know 40 45 because
often I speak to people where that can
be like a real you know hard mountain to
climb and get over so what are some of
the things that you've invested in or
how different yeah what are some of the
things that are really different if
we're to look in your business could be
infrastructure could be the weather you
set up the leadership team I don't know
how different does it look it changes
and I always heard this number I think
12 is one of the mile times and 28 was
the next one the business really does
change quite a lot
um and I would always I always say to
people if you're looking to absolutely
maximize the bottom line for your
lifestyle you have your business set
kind of eight to twelve people you don't
need loads of sophistication and
complication in
um support service and things we're kind
of at that stage now where we're like
with that I call it the small mid
business where actually I now need to
labor in tons of costs right now to give
us the opportunity to grow in
infrastructure in town acquisition in
finance and compliance and technology in
extra offices for scalability like I'm
just throwing costs in at the moment I'm
an awkward place where I'm not I was
profitable when I was fewer people but
to get to What's Next Level I have to do
it so
um
I think if you also look at it kind of
almost sometimes between 45 and 30
sometimes the extra heads are the heads
that aren't fee generating so that's the
bigger difference is when we were
smaller and younger everybody was fee
generating as you get bigger you start
increasing the percentage of people that
are non-feed generating and as a result
those people work slightly differently
to recruiters having to understand how a
marketeer works in your business how
someone in finance worked how your
office managers work like they're very
different types of characters
um that have different expectations of
the role they're rewarded in different
way commission like recruiters were like
yeah you want to you don't want to put
the hours you don't own the commission
it's quite simple you're looking at it
differently so the biggest difference is
that is the infrastructure it's the cost
of the infrastructure um of course the
upsides are you get to bring in more
technology and you can automate certain
things and you can have better
scalability and purchasing power and
there's more people but
um we're at that complicated stage where
I feel like when we kind of get to 60 70
80 Say it'll be easier because I'll then
have more Recruiters in that can get
them benefit of the scalability so
um how does it change it changes because
you don't intimately know everything
about everyone and when we were 10 12
people I knew every process that was
going on and every every new clients
every deal that could drop by you every
candidate I knew every Runner and I
could speak to any client and be like I
knew what would the pre now I'm in a
position where I might go out to certain
clients and they're talking about
process that I don't know as much about
so I you become more reliant on others
to have a deeper knowledge of it and
trusting that what they say is actually
fact and not just trying to make it look
like a mistake's not being hidden yeah
so I think people find it helpful if you
can describe a bit more on like what
that actually infrastructure looks like
or how it looks like today because I'm
assuming what you're saying there is
you're you're sort of creating a
business that needs to look how it does
today so you can thank yourself for and
like you know and when you're 60 70
people or like yeah making those sort of
decisions now so then yeah Things become
a lot more easier as you said as you get
bigger so obviously out of the so with
this let's just say 45 people how many
people on would we put under the you
know fee generating and then how many
people would example and I don't know
you might have an operations person
office manager doesn't know talk to us a
bit about that because I think that'll
be useful well you're looking about 20
of the business are just in non-feed
generating roles or indirect fee
generating so marketing so we are of
course we're trying to generate more
than digital marketing more inbound
leads so that therefore we can fit but
not directly I couldn't look at every
pound that that person's billing for me
anymore
um to an extent Finance sits in there
because they're trying to save you cost
in certain areas to make it worthwhile
but 20 of the business will sit in
non-feed generating you then got
probably at least 20 slightly more that
are
fee generating at lower level so they're
now leading groups look at myself I
build a lot more personally directly
five years ago to what I built today
because I now got a Workforce that's
doing it so you then end up with a
management leadership group that based
upon the size of their teams either rfe
generous or some of them might be
generating for a lower so you start like
typical recruit you start developing
people into roles or who can be great
builders that don't bill as much anymore
as long as they can build through others
so you end up with lots if you take the
per pound person of the whole business
will you make
less per pound per person for everyone
in the business including support than
we would have
um kind of a while ago so I think when
you go 28 upwards which that was the
number that was always said to me that's
where sophistication gets a little
that's where you're laboring in more
costs so that would be I mean we've got
technology to be
um serving and looking at engagement
within the workforce we've got
technology to support automation of
marketing or different bits and pieces
for the for a social brand so there's
all these things we've been putting in
that actually we've needed to to help
the business to get scale
um and it can be like at the time is it
only it's just like well I'm going to go
on a journey the next few years where we
could be making more money Top Line but
maybe making less money bottom line but
you've got to accept the fact that
you're rolling the dice for growth just
like you did at the front end of your
business and accept the fact that
um and if you don't want to accept that
then admit the fact that you're just a
lifestyle business now that's not a
problem but that's what your business
then becomes so for me it's building a
business of Legacy a business that has
scalability and you are putting things
in that have cost and accept the fact
that you get a more expensive Workforce
and trying to keep measures in per pound
event NFI spent on staff costs I think
it's really important so how much of the
total nfis or the margin that's been
generated not the revenue that you're
generating are you giving back to the
workforce what's that percentage how
much what percentage of that is
basically being spent to run the
business so non-free earners plus
um office insurance and all the other
bits a bit and then what's left and they
always say you're looking at that
conversion of NFI to kind of ebit or
kind of profit before tax PBT as it were
everyone wants to get to 30 plus reality
most people are 20 25 when you're
investing it could be worse than that so
it's it's trying to now be a little bit
more corporate with what you're looking
at and looking at the numbers and
setting some measures that are sensible
for you and stick into them and when
you're spending too much on on on the
support staff of the business and your
sales aren't making more then looking at
the reality of is it working are the
support people working is what you
planned working and you need to scale
that back to go again what do you think
has been we don't need like a person I
don't need to think about like that
Oneness conversation what do you think
um has been the best
um most impactful on the business from a
non-feed generating standpoint what's
been the most impactful hire you've made
so far that you think has had the most
impact on the business could be
operations could be marketing could be
Finance I don't know what your thoughts
are on that everything's I think
all of them have added in different ways
if I go over the period of 10 years that
we've been running I'd say when I bought
him essentially who my FD is today who
kind of heads up that whole kind of
support operations with an FC at the
time made the biggest difference to
probably how we looked at things because
I was at that time Outsourcing Finance
to my business partners Associates and
paid me a commercial so no difference
you go into an accountancy firm and
giving it to them hiring him was really
expensive at the time because it was
cheaper to Outsource it to them than it
was for me to hire someone to do it
myself and I only had one person not a
whole team of people that are tax
experts that was really impactful
because it abled it enabled me to
probably as a scientist I love my data
so I'm very good at the numbers I was
always good with management accounts and
things like even though I've never done
a business course or Finance course in
my life I've studied sales and science
um most impactful because it was someone
else keeping a closer grip on those
things someone else generating new ways
of looking at Financial metrics to
support me somebody else who was able to
help me to build some of the non-feed
generation inside of the business that
could enable the business looking at Roi
of that side of the car so that was a
really big impact to me
um if you started tomorrow morning you
wouldn't necessarily go and hire an fcfd
unless they're putting money in it and
being a shareholder right they're
expensive at what point did you hire
that person um we were probably about
five years in we're about halfway
through the business that I bought that
person in and I'm like well I'm going
not just bringing an accountant I bought
in a full-blown FC who was actually
operating more at an FD level but was
prepared to come on the journey with me
and take a bit of a hit for a while so
how many of you were there in the
business at around that time roughly
honestly I cannot remember numbers I
really can't if I was doing it tomorrow
morning if I hired one non-feed
generating person it would be a market
too it'd be a social marketer because
they're going to enable you to push your
brand hard maybe to build the brand in
the right way to be conscious of that
and actually generate a whole bunch of
leads that maybe when I started I saw
some good leads because I got a bit of a
spotlight of ah this guy the science
crew he's been on like The Apprentice
Prince although it never got me a direct
role it showed more curiosity that you
can't underestimate getting some really
decent leads coming into your business
that you can convert quite quickly just
to get some money in the pot quickly now
I really like that Finance
um point there just because
um a lot of people start business on
their own
um it'd be really interesting to see the
percentages of how many people that
start a business on their own would say
that uh Finance
um and managing money is like their
strongest skill set particularly in
recruitment most recruitment companies
that I know that have been started up in
the last few years and are a handful of
people plus the the owner is absolutely
clueless to the numbers I mean I'm
really clueless I mean the science
that's in me men are methodical meant I
like numbers and data so actually I look
at patterns you know it worked for me
but there are a lot of very gifted sales
people that are not very good with the
data and the numbers so
um there's more of them than not yeah so
I really like that because I think yeah
the more visibility that you can have on
like you said the things like we spend X
pound and we get this back or a lot I
think that they're really important
particularly when you're you're scaling
you're adding more caution you're only
going to have more confidence in doing
that if you know what it should mean in
another year's time or two years time if
that compounds and we have things right
so I think that's such a great share so
look as we as we come to um we're also
with that person the right Finance
person because I could sit here and say
there's this bit of tech it looks great
oh it's going to revolutionize what we
do
um and there's loads of great bits of
tackle ways of doing it but and I'll put
it in as a leader as an owner and I
think that's great I've spent money on
that I believe in it and I'm not really
probably looking at the measure because
I've made the call right my ego's saying
it's the right call what the finance
person is going to be able to do all the
marketing manager will be able to do is
continue to look at the ROI the value of
what they're doing it and how you'll use
it and keeping you sharp on that's
really important um be it the front end
of your business you don't want to
become so corporate so data heavy that
you don't build heart and a flare of how
your business works so for me it was the
right stage to bring some I'd
established like the HRS way
um as opposed to being Ricky's way when
he started so I'd establish what worked
for us and then bringing that person who
helped us to move on
so what what's uh what's next for you
guys then big one for us is more markets
um so I think when you are so doing life
science and for us life science is
actually the medicines within Life
Sciences the companies who make
medicines and take it to patients what
we're not is every type of science
business which is what some Life
Sciences are they'll do anything
chemical
um consumer good we're just medicines on
the medicine side so when you are in a
in a tight space the only way you can
chose true scale is who either
generalized no of interest to me by a
chemistry doesn't want to start doing
admin recruitment to my clients no
interest
you either globalize so you start going
into more markets take the same service
proposition then figure out a way to
understand cultural difference in other
countries and how they operate and how
you build a team there
um that's kind of your two real roots or
you build other service lines in there
or you just do everything but really for
me it's it's when I say globalize I
don't want it to sound ridiculous the
amount of recruitment companies have
been going for two minutes they're like
we're it we're Global we've got office I
know you've got four or five virtual
offices on websites that you pay for
that sound great with different phone
numbers
um so for us it would be trying to do
more international business and the next
step is the US I don't hide any anything
about it it's the biggest
um medicines country in the world if
that makes sense in terms of the FDA and
how they operate and the drugs that are
coming out and the standard of those
drugs so that's what we're going to be
looking at
um which is the next step which we're
really starting to kick off shortly like
slow and steady to start with I'm not
going to sit here and say that a
business is going to be 90 us within 12
months absolutely not I've I've hired
two people that are joining me shortly I
back those people to help me to grow
that business and we're gonna we're
gonna build it in the right way and then
and find a scaling past that point
anything surprises so far
um it's not a surprise because it should
be human knowledge just that the margins
and the appetite in the us is
unbelievable
um versus the UK right there's fewer
recruitment companies in the US and that
are in the UK yet the economy is eight
times the size so it's like logic is it
you should be a nice industry but a lot
of people in the UK have already done it
they've already run over there to do it
I'm behind the game on that that side of
the fence but my service proposition
well I mean we're called hyper right
sounded like an American Business I love
that look Ricky thanks so much um
appreciate the honesty I think you kept
it real thank you I've had a friend of
you spoken about
um yeah I think it's been a really
interesting Journey for you know I
always respect people that have been
doing the same thing for a long period
of time because that is hard to
do you know it's hard in today's world
like you could easily you know you might
have picked up the pro wrestling uh
thing again or you might have gone in
this direction but you've done you focus
on what you're great at what you enjoy
for a decade I'm sure more years to come
and I really respect that so thanks for
coming on the Pod thank you mate
appreciate it thank you so much for
listening to the episode I hope you
enjoyed it and got value from the
conversation if you did enjoy it please
don't forget to like share and subscribe
and we'll see you in the next episode